hey 42 here cave paintings are
incredibly special not only are they the
very first form of graphical
communication envisioned by mankind but
they are the most tangible connection we
have with our ancient ancestors who
lived had families hunted did chores
played and inevitably died tens of
thousands of years ago how do we know
they did all those things because the
marks upon these rocks tell us they are
a rich tapestry of human life its ups
and downs carved into stone and
preserved within a hidden sanctum for
millennia the oldest cave painting we
have discovered is that of a bull in
Indonesia it is thought to be at least
40,000 years old but could be up to 50
2,000 years old most cave paintings
however have been discovered in Western
Europe specifically France and Spain an
impressive 350 caves containing
prehistoric art have been unearthed in
these two countries alone our ancestors
created odds to understand their world
these remarkable images signify an epoch
in human history when Homo sapiens
stopped simply surviving and started
pausing to contemplate their
surroundings perhaps even enjoy them for
a brief quiet moment within the solitude
of their dark subterranean retreats one
of the most telling portraits of basic
human joy a mr. hostile world can be
seen on the world of the quavered de las
manos meaning cave of hands in Argentina
though at first it may look like the
scene of some horrific mass execution
this is in fact the polar opposites
these stencil paintings were created by
children and their parents placing their
palms against the rocks and blowing
paint as it threw a hollowed-out bow to
impress the outline of their hands up
the rock the black paint was made from
charcoal taken from the embers of their
fire and the red is aqua which is
basically clay rich in iron oxide giving
it a blood red hue
both pigments would have been mixed with
animal fats to give them a paint like
consistency what was the point of doing
this you may ask well it's quite simple
really play what you can see here is
prehistoric man playing with their
families in the same way that parents
finger paint with their children today
but they used their artistic expression
for more than just recreation recent
discoveries have led researchers to now
think that they actually created
humanity's first written language and in
fact some of these cave paintings were
communications to others and perhaps
messages left to rival tribes friendly
tribes or family members in most of the
caves in France and Spain where this
artwork can be found alongside the
skillful impressions of bison and horses
are a bunch of mysterious symbols for a
long time it was thought that they had
little to no significance and were only
drawn as a means of practice but only in
very recent years have specialists began
to collate all of these symbols from
hundreds of caves into one single
unified codex and what they discovered
blew their minds the same or at least or
mistake ibly similar symbols have been
found in hundreds of different caves
hundreds of miles apart from one another
genevieve von pet singer from the
University of Victoria in British
Columbia has a particular interest in
these symbols and has traveled all over
Europe recording their appearances in
total she has found 32 distinct symbols
that are repeated over and over again
from simple circles to ladder shapes
it is possible each could represent a
specific animal or object
this could be a horse for example but it
gets even more intriguing because the
symbols are often found in sequences for
example lines next to dots and these
same sequences can be seen in different
caves in different countries over and
over again almost like a language we are
the only animals on our planet that are
able to communicate basic concepts via
abstract shapes and that we were doing
it over 40,000 years ago is remarkable
and these symbols are nothing if not a
teaser to an explanation of how Homo
sapiens were able to dominate the
environment around us and create
advanced civilizations something that
Nova species has ever been successful in
doing but occasionally when intrepid
explorers uncover a previously
undiscovered cave in some dark corner of
the world they find more than animal
shapes and symbols sometimes they find
something altogether more disturbing
near the town of Jarama
in the canker region of India our caves
that contain some of the most mysterious
prehistoric paintings we have ever
discovered they show odd looking
humanoids with long limbs tall necks and
bulbous heads these paintings date back
10,000 years some researchers are
convinced that these are graphical
recounts of the first encounter with
extraterrestrials some of the figures
are wearing helmets with antennae like
shapes protruding from the top and this
particular drawing in the same cave
resembles a disc-shaped UFO craft with
three legs or are they tractor beams
perhaps the truth is we currently have
no way of knowing what really happened
on that day 10,000 years ago to cause
our ancestors to paint such strange
images but what makes the whole
situation even
keya is that they are not the only cave
paintings that seemed to resemble over
worldly beings take for instance these
disturbing paintings found in the
Sunstone cliffs of the Sager Canyon in
Utah painted roughly 8,000 years ago
they feature a variety of humanoids with
bizarre body shapes some appears to be
holding snakes and have snake-like
antennas on their heads these particular
figures are known as - book horn wash
angels and this painting shows what
appears to be a cult-like meeting there
was a circle of people around a tall of
individual who looks like a giant alien
robots and finally there is the artwork
of the Aboriginal people the one genus
inhabitants of the Kimberley region of
Northwest Australia for at least sixty
thousand years they left us with this
striking rock house of slender men with
huge craniums and eyes in fact these
paintings are so close to the modern-day
pop culture interpretations of
extraterrestrials that it has convinced
many conspiracy theorists that these
people genuinely received a visit from
another world all those thousands of
millenia ago but perhaps there's just
something inherent within our idea of
what other people would look like
that hasn't changed through the ages
however the charama
Sega Canyon and when Gina paintings may
all share a common explanation that's
more THC than ET more rational and Afra
apologists suspect all these examples
are the result of possible drug adult
shamanism anthropologists believe that
shamanism in various forms was an
intrinsic part of prehistoric life in
most cultures if we forget about robot
aliens for just a moment then it's
difficult not to see an obvious
shamanism ritual represented in this
particular painting in Sega Canyon but
research is now believed that the
majority of these old paintings were
created under the influence of
psychedelic drugs we imagine drugs to be
a modern invention
and indeed all refined drugs are but
apart from synthetic drugs such as meth
all natural drugs have to come from
nature and indeed many of the sauce
plants of modern drugs do come from very
recent cultivations in the span of human
history but plants have existed on earth
for perhaps millions and definitely tens
of thousands of years that have the
ability to significantly alter neural
activity such as an ancestor of the
hallucinogenic ayahuasca plant which is
still used by many tribal communities
today a paper published by researchers
in Tokyo suggests that not only would a
prehistoric man used those plants during
their spiritual rituals but they would
have actually sorts them out and
collected them for future use by using
psychedelic plants they would have been
able to derive greater meaning from
their rituals as they would have visions
of wild faces shapes and places that
they could never see in the real world
the Tokyo research has found the same
crazy patterns repeated in different
caves across the world this would give
credence to the psychedelics theory as
there are indeed specific patterns that
the human brain tends to see under the
influence of psychedelic drugs these are
collectively known as touring
instabilities we see these patterns
because they represent the layout of our
brains we are seeing visualizations of
our neural pathways which when you think
about it is really trippy we are able to
see these patterns on psychedelics
because they enable neurons to talk to
other neurons that they would otherwise
never be able to communicate with
imagine for a moment that your brain is
a series of adjacent rivers running down
a hillside with many tributaries
but psychedelic drugs such as LSD allow
those rivers to overflow and float the
mountainside suddenly all these rivers
and tributaries can now exchange
information with others previously
unreachable and when that happens you
get weird like this
what's more Stone Age man didn't just
eat psychedelic plants he smoked them to
archaeologists from University College
London and North Carolina State
University recently unearthed ceramic
bowls and tubes on the Caribbean island
of Kerry aku
it's believed this equipment was used
during social gatherings and spiritual
rituals to inhale the fumes from
psychedelic substances the most likely
candidate for such a drug is coho burr
made from the ground-up seeds of the
coach of Bana tree this cave painting
actually depicts an individual using a
makeshift device to inhale Cahawba so
there you go our ancestors spent their
days trying not to get eaten and laying
around inside caves getting high
prehistoric man didn't have the
Internet's but if he did he would
definitely use Nord VPN Nord VPN have
kindly sponsored today's video they have
thousands of superfast servers in over
60 countries nor VPN uses military-grade
encryption and has absolutely no data
logging it works on any device Android
iOS Windows Mac Linux you name it you
can even run Nord VPN directly on your
router so all of your devices are
automatically protected I travel a lot
and I often do sensitive work on my
laptop banking messaging private
documents etc in places like coffee
shops in other public spaces but I
always use non VPN in those instances
because it's so easy for hackers to
intercept your packets over a public
Wi-Fi network and see everything you're
doing online nor VPN there will encrypt
your data so you can use any Wi-Fi
connection 4G or 5g and know you're
completely protected and your data is
secure take control of your internet
experience today with Nord VPN and right
now you can get 70% off a free year plan
plus one additional month for free when
you go to no VPN com slash 40 or use
code 48 check
this special offer makes your
subscription just three dollars 49 per
month that's not VPN comm sauce 42 take
control of your internet again thanks
for watching subscribe for a new video
every week and a big thank you to the
sponsor not VPN don't forget to check
them out the links in the description